America has just carried out air strikes
in eastern Syria against houthi groups
after they shot down a US drone so we
want to get to Jennifer Griffin this
just broke uh you have more for us
Jennifer uh Dana this was um what I can
say is that US military sources tell us
that uh the US military has carried out
air strikes in eastern Syria it wouldn't
have been against houti forces but
against Iranian backed proxies who have
been firing rockets and drones onto US
bases 41 attacks on us troops and bases
since October 17th uh we're getting more
details now but these air strikes uh
were carried out we're told just moments
ago they're just getting the bomb damage
assessment we don't know how many
locations but you can uh if based on the
last air pair of air strikes on October
26 uh the US was would likely be
targeting unmanned uh warehouses storage
facilities the question is how many of
those Iranian back uh proxy BAS
uh will they have targeted tonight will
they have used f-16s f-15s as we
reported earlier just about an hour or
two ago uh an mq9 Reaper was shot down
over the Red Sea by houti forces in
Yemen so far we do not have any word of
any retaliatory strike by the US
military at this time but this is new
and breaking as we speak uh Dana based
on uh senior US military sources so
Jennifer why
now why now I think that they have been
watching their there's a very D there's
a very dangerous Matrix of events that
are happening right now obviously the uh
deterrence of those that pair of air
strikes uh was not enough to stop these
Iranian uh proxies uh but as we speak uh
CIA director Bill Burns is in Cutter
trying to negotiate uh the release of
American hostages in Gaza uh those are
delicate uh talks being headed up by
cutter uh and so carrying out air
strikes right now it's it's a very
delicate time so I think there there are
a number of considerations the the Biden
Administration has said that they don't
want to spread the conflict but they are
also very clear that the Iranians and
their proxy forces don't seem to be
getting the message many of these
rockets and drones are falling short of
the basis but in those first two days
after October 17th there were 42
Americans who were injured with
concussions some TBI brain injuries two
of them had to be sent to land stool um
nobody has been killed yet by these
attacks but it's only a matter of time
and so there's a great deal of concern
at us Central Command that if they don't
regain some sort of deterrence and Iran
doesn't get the message that their proxy
forces need to stop these attacks so
that's why it's happening now I think uh
there were a number of reasons uh that
they waited until uh this week but um
we'll see we'll see if Iran gets the
message all right judge Janine has a
question for you hi Jennifer it's uh
they're not just relying on the the
missile defense systems now we're
actually uh carrying out air strikes in
Syria uh is is that what I'm that's what
you're saying that's what's new tonight
uh judge these are we don't know the
number of air strikes but I was told on
very good authority from a senior US
military source that the US has carried
out a series of air strikes tonight we
don't know the locations we'll be
getting that information in the coming
uh coming hour I believe and uh but this
is different than every one of these
bases where you have 900 US troops in
Syria you have 2500 in Iraq those bases
uh where they have been some are small
outposts been attacked with these
rockets and drones in recent days and
weeks uh they have certainly missile
defense they have means to to stop those
drones and they have been shooting down
those drones each uh most of the drones
have been shot down by US forces at
those bases this is different this is
sending in uh either f-15s or f-16s to
carry out air strikes on Iranian backed
targets proxy forces in eastern Syria
it's significant that they are targeting
in eastern Syria and not in Iraq even
though most of the attacks have been
actually at uh bases in Iraq by these
proxy forces there's a great deal of
concern at the highest levels of the
Pentagon and at the in the
administration not wanting to
destabilize the Iraqi government the
Iraqi government is not uh is you know
it would be very easy to um to have the
the you know there's a very delicate
balance between the Shia the Sunni and
the US does not want to see the Iraqi
government fall and then Iran move in
fully and create that Shia Crescent from
tan all the way to Beirut Jennifer thank
you for the breaking news we appreciate
it